a triple on Berlin's waterways could
easily begin here at slant but run Z the
open-air Lido on the lake of the same
name tens of thousands of people enjoy
its fine sandy beach in the summer once
it gets its water from the half the
second longest river in Berlin after the
spree which feeds into it the buildings
designed in the late 1920s in the server
style known as Noah's Akhilesh kite new
objectivity are now protected as
historical monuments
axel OTT was boss here for more than 40
years the former beach attendant is
possibly the biggest fan of the complex
there Zant is fast car even the sand is
almost like in the Caribbean we have
more than a kilometer of beach if you've
seen the sunset here you'll cancel your
vacation so buy a season ticket to
become a regular here been here some gas
or you can travel further into the city
from the pier not far from the beach it
takes three hours to reach the center of
Berlin along the half and the spring
[Music]
years
Berlin has some 200 kilometres of
navigable canals and about a thousand
bridges captain amazi lega who's been
flying its waters for over 30 years says
the German capital has one of the
largest systems of waterways of any
European city
but he was in Cana boats is Valen was
built from barges in other words all the
building materials were brought here by
barge Berlin would be unthinkable
without its waterways after 2 hours you
approach the city center along the way
there's a great deal of modern
architecture after German reunification
a veritable construction boom took place
on the banks of the stream
and this is where Angela Merkel has her
office the federal Chancellery it was
the first building in what's now the
government and parliamentary district
the main railway station is diagonally
across from it at the final destination
museum island it's well worth going
ashore and following the music
the urban Beach Hodge sand bar meter
doesn't boast any sand but he does host
regular dance events just the thing for
a splendid summer evening in Berlin
[Music]